foreign
was from North Carolina my mom was from
Georgia
and um I was raising a lot of them
I mean Fort Lauderdale you don't think
of as being a typically
problematic Hood no no no no no but in
the 60s and 70s if you were from the
city it was real rough it was rough from
the city
we got a lot of Jamaicans a lot of
Haitians in that area
I guess there's always certain
neighborhoods there yes yes like Taylor
Town Parkway
uh real Trace different areas tell me
about your parents well my mom was
alcoholic she was alcoholic
and uh she never stayed home much but my
father my father was an old gangster at
uh Chicago
uh
and uh it was a Walt better too he came
by the military he loaded guns he ran
number houses and
that's what I learned
miles bringing from him
how would you see what he did
well I used to watch him all the time to
go with him a lot to get my direct ball
when I was seven eight years old in the
pool room stick out pool room how you
direct balls
and my dad was a pool shooter he loves
to shoot pool he was six six he was real
tall
so he loves to shoot pool so he's always
stick in his car following him
everywhere he went yeah but shooting
pool and uh murdering people is a
different story it was a different story
but it was in the same
same uh group
my father also was a pimp so being a
pimp and a gambler a person that shot
pool
um and a person that sold drugs
you know so every violence in that it
was violence in that so my father went
to prison when I was young for murder
how old are you I was about six years
old my father went to prison
I was six
and how would you describe your
childhood in general
well my childhood really came from um
from when I was born so I was eight
years old
stay with my parents in Fort Lauderdale
but when I was eight years old an
accident happened that sent me to an
open Home in New York
and I was putting on open on
um matter of fact what happened was my
grandfather he's always come to the side
of the house and scare everybody and
after this the 12 gauge shotgun and I
blowed his head off I was eight years
old and I was sent to um Castell New
York and then where I met Mike Tyson
that was in the same off at home but he
wasn't known as Iron Mike Tyson then he
was just whatever I used to pick on him
because he taught it funny where they
call them names and he was um fight
everybody and later on in life he became
famous as I'm Mike Tyson
so you you murdered your grandfather I'm
ruining my grandfather it's not your
intention no by accident by accident and
um
I was sent away and off at home eight
years old and eight years old and I was
in the office I used to be a bruise
um about older people there it's an
older lady name is Maddie she'd be there
everybody beat us and Lockers in the
closet
stuff like that yeah
we pee the bed she make you stay in your
pee you know stuff like that so my brain
was tough
did you have other lines of work that
you wanted to go into oh yes I wanted to
always own my own company
um I wanted on my own
um plumbing company on roofing company
and stuff like that to help out
who are you closer to your mom or dad
wow close to my father
because he'd take me in the woods and
shoot my shoot guns I was young you're
shooting guns at what age age five or
six like a little Indigo I can clean in
the gun he'd beat me and teach me that
I can bring a 45 down
put it back together in the dark
that was just five years old
and then you
you graduate high school no that's your
fried fried Chico I went to fifth grade
fifth grade field grade Falls education
ever had
and you
ended up doing what well when I went to
um New York I was offering home there
for two years top of 10 years old then I
came back to Florida I stayed in
Jacksonville with my sister and she was
married to a dude named dungus he was
the leader of the Jamaican pastor and
the day they had a big drug rain and I
stayed up under him
he top of 16.
he'd take me everywhere with him and
they had a big uh kill his privilege to
go around just killing people he was the
head of Jamaica part of the shower
possum they called it
and did that kind of lead you into a
path where you're doing more of this
kind of stuff yeah they made me in the
wrong path but it lead me to think that
it was okay when it wasn't okay it led
me into uh misunderstand people in
society I was taught the wrong way
so I thought it was cool y'all kill
people
you murdered you think well together
they said with 39.
and what kind of people are you
murdering well drug dealers
companies informers
confidential informants so so somebody
has
the courts or the police whatever have
somebody who is going to inform on
somebody they're trying to put away yeah
somebody trying to testify I guess uh
they are hiring me to do the job to stop
him
get rid of them get rid of them yes
that's gonna piss the judge and the cops
off yeah that pissed them off nobody
hate me they didn't like me
and how do you how do you do it well
first thing I do is uh money got to be
first you got to pay off half half price
first I find a little case of where they
at
and then uh when the Protection Program
um
there's people there's people who always
find an inside job that people work in
the courthouse get information for
Clerks of the courts people that you
grow up with people that's in your
neighborhood
um Cricket polices get in contact with
you know who I wouldn't grow up with in
middle school stuff like that out of my
neighborhood I get information from them
kind of people
they appointment the right direction
how old are you now well 52 years old
52. then you spent most of your life
either in about 29 years in prison I was
16. I was four to seven when I got out
of the youngest man in the State of
Florida to go to Florida death Pro
so you've been convicted of some of
these murders I've been completely uh
six months six they sent me the Florida
death row
for 29 15 years on death bro 29 years in
Florida prison
the Florida Supreme Court overturned my
commission
and do you what kind of emotions do you
go through now with these kind of
this this kind of history of yours well
I changed my life I gave my life to God
and uh I used to have more nightmares
and stuff like that and I became a
changed man
so it did it did haunt you it haunted me
every day of my life
yeah I can't imagine
you can just do that kind of stuff and
move on with your life like nothing
happens it's hard to it's hard to it's
hard to
you know when you're uneducated when you
come on this Postman family and when you
was raised wrong you were taught wrong
when you thought that you would taught
right so you did wrong things but as you
grew in life and you better yourself and
educated yourself
you begin to do what is right
and that will happen with me and you've
been out for how long now I've been out
now
um all together
um two years two years
and you're you're trying to take a
different direction with your life yes
sir I'm a manager at uh U-Haul
very productive
with your criminal record it's going to
be hard it was hard to get it was hard
to get but when you change your life
people really understand you
they really understanding when you're
serious make a change
but the federal government keep
following me anywhere I go they got with
anchor monster home stuff like that I
still have one case left
um that he's trying to investigate
and stuff like that and
your father is around still or is he
gone and my father passed my father
passed did you ever talk to him after
you became kind of default his in his
footsteps
well my father always been my idol on my
mentor all my life and he he would
taught me wrong because he's dead
um was a pimp so he did taught him wrong
and the pain that he had inside of him
he only passed that down to me
you know so I had to break that cycle to
pass not pass that pain down to my kids
what do you think the problem is with
these kind of communities well why does
this happen well the problem is that
when
you come from this personal background
dysfunctional thinking in Vietnam see my
problem came up here no and they was
given Heron they was giving drugs they
were giving Addiction in the war so when
he left on the wall and the uh
government didn't support them they went
on their own to create their own things
and there was a lot I was doing they
were dealing with drugs they were
dealing with pimping they were dealing
with discreet life and that's all he
knew cause he kept on his personal
family so the only thing my father was
able to teach me is just functional
things backwards things
but I have to break that cycle and not
use that to my kid how did you go about
breaking that cycle well personally I
did I I knew I had to I had to change my
life I found a good woman and uh the
Community Kitchen was great and um I
knew as I got older and got mature that
when my father was teaching me and what
I had learned and plus I did 15 years on
death row so I need to read consonant
you had a lot of time to think I had a
lot of time to think about my life and
what life itself was how do you meet a
good woman giving your background in
your 20 years of your life believe it or
not I met a Snappers
um and it totally changed my life it
totally changed my life a very special
woman did it yeah she gave me a son to
live to hang in there with you yeah yeah
and I tell people about my testimony my
testimony from Death Row to the front of
you I'm also a pastor at a church and uh
God is amazing what he does he's amazing
when you truly want to change yourself
when you want to change
you know a change come you do the right
things people place the thing you
changes and I feed the homies I give
back to the community
um a lot of people family father that I
killed I I communicate with their kids
really yeah I couldn't make with three
young and um I gotta give back to them
did you ever escape with drugs or
alcohol or anything like that well I
never was uh addicted to drugs alcohol
nothing like that but my mom and my
father was yeah and I was around it for
years
but I became a drug dealer I became a
joiner I so play the drugs Clinton drug
all around the world
and so so you go by the name four or
five that's what uh that's what that
name came from
uh douglas douglas and Jamaican 51 they
were the leader of the shower pasta and
and at a very young age from 10 11 I can
shoot so good with a 45. he said you
know what that's your name you just
shoot you shoot too good really go out
in the field and shoot bottles and stuff
so they said that's the only gun I ever
committed crime with that's the only gun
I ever kill people with how would you go
about killing people
well first of all got to be the right
price
he paid the right ticket they got
underground black markets numbers that
you can call and they'll tell you it's a
ticket in your area
you know there's a weather ticket in
Miami and I said well I want two of them
tickets and then I said they'll tell me
the price on the tickets and then I I
know the name or the individuals and
then I just
had like a normal person in the
neighborhood and they don't know me I
get a girl from somewhere and they don't
even know and I set them up with a girl
and I had a girl that had like she liked
them and she don't even know them he
don't know her and we get back to the
motel I follow him
girl too
that was your party like then
how do you do it well I'm a trainer just
shoot him in the head
three shots an idiot so anybody I was
ever accused of killing
that became my trademark so the state
attorney scene ain't nobody shot three
times behind the hill with a 45 they was
coming to get me
they didn't care
so I won nine nine murder trials
Broward County alone
three in Jacksonville
and two in New York
so you've been convicted how many times
I make a video one time that I was 16
that sent me the death row but since
I've been away from Death Row soon I got
out I called another murder case
after any kind of jail for you finding
Johnny Ross birthday cake that's one of
the biggest birdie kids of all he was a
big companies and farmer against uh
minor police privilege cops the minor
Police Department he was telling them
Cricket police so the cricket police
were
I was paid this I would pay about it who
hired you a police officer and a drug
that hired me to kill Johnny Ross yeah
level 2016 that was the last murder case
you got a movie here
Maybe
emotionally how did this affect you well
mostly um at night sometimes I can't
sleep I talk to turn a lot I I hear the
bosses
of the people like special uh Johnny
Ross case because I knew him personally
he he the only guy
yeah I ever was accused of killing that
I knew personally I knew him personally
and um it's gonna be hard and when I
took the detail he got in the car he
said man please don't give me
you know that
so he knows you're going to kill him and
I shot him three times behind here
having one block from Broward
um Broward County Courthouse
eight o'clock in the morning coming from
winning Protection Program
I stayed up three nights stepping and
stuff in the field down the street for
three nights watching
and only the only time I was able to get
to her we went uh the detective was
taking him but it did Teddy was a fat
dude that was out of shape and I brought
a gun on him first I took his gun and I
threw him out of the car I could talk
about it now because I won a trial can't
nobody retry me on it the figures can't
really try me on it I can't win some of
some of your cases
well I look at it now
anything that my calling for God and
that was that's why I changed my life
God ain't a good lawyer yeah I had a
good luck Christopher Clark had a
Cincinnati I flew him down into Florida
Christopher Clark he won all together 12
murder cases for me
he won 12 cases 12 murder case all
together how did he win 12 cases well
not yes or not giving not given that's
yourself yeah yeah
the American case is the harder case to
convince because there can't be no uh
speculations you gotta have side effects
y'all were never on camera can't be no
doubts I've never video no I went all
that I went this came up there so after
you would do the deed whether you went
into somebody's apartment car or
whatever
do you just walk away or do you run away
or I'll walk away normally get in the
car and just going by myself walking
their dog down the street wouldn't
suspect you of doing anything no just
for you to be casual
just be casual casual act normal
and that was it
you got a story or two I'm sure you do
well
um yeah yeah
tell me what
well uh
I I want people to be able to hear my
story because
I didn't know how did I get to that
point
um coming from this functional family
this functional background being a Bruce
as a child
and had me taught me wrong he called me
to do a lot of wrong things in life
and a lot of parents need to understand
that that they granddadded and they
follow us got their hurt in that pain in
them they pass it down to their kids
and uh that affected my life I could
have been an NFL player I could have
been a basketball if I could have been
anything other than uh being a higher
hit man
you know there's a lot of talent that
they've been waste in situation like
that
but if some of the murders that you've
committed tell me tell me a story or two
of how it went down oh
Johnny B is a dude named Johnny Bean in
Jacksonville
you stay on the top floor of Hilltop uh
projects and everybody was scheduled
you need to be there by with a bat
he originally from Miami but he was
getting money in Jacksonville and
everybody was cut agenda being and I
told this girl I said you know what I'm
gonna kill Johnny Bean what was Johnny
being into Johnny B was into drugs he
was a big drug dealer he was sending
drugs a lot no he was going to be
women's I watched my father beat my mom
and I hated on guys that beat women
and he beat this girl up that I was
messing with and I told that girl I said
you know what tomorrow when I come over
there I'm gonna blow on kind of being
hit off
I guess he thought I would like she said
you're so small I used to be real small
he's so small he's so big I said I
promise you that and uh I had to go to
the ninth floor
and uh I walked by at least 30 guys they
had gone
and I walked up there and blowed his
brains up
over the rail and walk back down by his
homeboys them and got in the car with my
friend he left
and everybody just looking around like
wow
because they was killing him
but I never had pill my apologies to
beat me with station called I wouldn't
cry
and I wouldn't cry you never had fear I
never had fear in my life never
I never had I was born with a hole in my
heart and a doctor told my mom that I
wouldn't live alone
I've always been a child that never
cried I get a woman I never cried Never
Cry dude to jump on me sometimes I get
in fights I never cry
I never said a tear
do you find you're developing those
abilities now that you're like to take a
new direction oh yes um I know we'll
believe I've been a manager and uh you
all
and they gave me another great
opportunity today
to be a supervisor
um or motivated to speak I go back to
jails I go to prison to talk to guys and
stuff I'm uh a deacon and a pastor in a
church
and um my lights have been wonderful now
it's been wonderful
and you do like public speaking right
like that yes I do public speaking I
speak all the time I feed the Homeless I
give back
to the community
um three guys who are mentor to uh was
accused of killing their fathers and
they called me and texted me out all the
time
and they're no bad blood no more
that's how life was how the game was
when you choose to be into that drug
game what do you think the answer is for
healing like what basketball is breaking
a cycle us as men's had to break that
cycle of being that pain in the anger
inside of us so we don't pass on to our
children and we've got to replace them
with love and love coming God do you
have kids
oh yeah okay I have step kids
after you murder somebody do
you just go out and have a beer or do
you like normalize it normal for me to
do I have a train to do it uh you don't
do anything different yeah it's nothing
enough just a job it's just a job the
other day at work
until it did work dogs state attorney
said when 39 people
um that I was involving and killings
um I don't know how many to be told
because in Chicago New York and
Washington uh Seattle
during that time
um if you Google it the shower pasta
there was a bit of 182 murders
and I know I was at least part of 60 60
or but they were charged with them
crying so nobody else can cannot be
charged with them but but
um
being around dysfunctional people you
know is part of the part of your
environment my mom was an alcoholic you
know my father was a drug dealer pimp
and a gangster so I was Tyrone I didn't
ask for that it was given to me but the
moment that I realized
that it wasn't the right thing to do I
changed my life
do you remember a point in your sounds
like your early youth
where you realize your life has taken
this crooked path yeah I was on Florida
death bro
in 1985. and they would buy to execute
on Theodore bunny Ted Bundy he didn't
see her next to me and I asked bunny I
said bunny
um you're gonna get executed tomorrow
and I said uh how do you feel he said
everything he says his everyday thing I
said but he told me he said I want you
to do you said what he told me he says
everyday thing yeah everyday thing it's
no big deal yeah don't be killed 30
people and them killing him he says
don't be there but he told me he said
you gonna get all death bro he said but
I want you to change your life
he said your your instant guy but you I
think you're probably different than Ted
Bundy you might have had a mental
illness he had another sickness cause he
was fattening off uh women that he would
choke and kill I never had a murder case
for the woman or a child every murder
case I ever had ever with drug dealers
uh
companies informing guys
that was in that life yeah and your your
violence stems from growing up growing
up I'm just positive family and a rough
family yeah it was wrong it wasn't like
you were a crazy person no I'm not one
of the crazies probably would have been
a problem I thought that if I was taught
the right way I don't win the college
you did the right thing but I would talk
wrong if you've grown up on the other
side of Fort Lauderdale you probably
would have been yeah but I grew up in
Africa it would have been different for
me in that area she's got Fifth Avenue
was a dangerous area for a lot of them
and not only me but every young young
child come from that area either had
life in prison either with a death row I
was a murderer at a young age
God that grew up with me was none of
successful in that area I can't name one
person in that whole entire area that
was successful really really none of all
of them were dead
people they were 15 16 are in prisonable
life
and that just reinforces all the
racism and the that's called the area a
lot of blacks for that area uh fathers
was in Vietnam so they were drug users
and stuff
and that type of immigration of area a
lot of people came from Georgia Carolina
New York and that part of Fort
Lauderdale on Fifth Avenue it was a more
dangerous area in Bravo County
you think there's any hope for the young
people of today that are kind of
following a similar path well yeah you
see it in big cities you know I'm I'm
based in L.A and I see I see it all the
time there yes everyone now uh they
don't have that father figure
and they've been taught the same avatar
from just pause the background
that second must be broke and part of is
the government the government is part
believe it or not they are part of
people being dysfunctional because
there's no programs for them there are
no no places for them the YMCA being
closed now
uh there's no place you can go at right
now
if you ain't in school or working that
you can do something positive there's
nowhere to go
and that's bad yeah I mean in your case
you kind of probably needed a series of
things to be different in your mind but
probably a mom that wasn't on drugs yeah
that maybe sold Insurance
yeah it's been a big difference and
maybe
a neighborhood that wasn't just yeah all
the kids was was crazy it was a lot of
Jamaicans a lot of Hastings in my
neighborhood during that time they were
very valid because they had just come
from Jamaica and then go Cuba uh Cubans
and they just let them out of prison
so our home of guys when I was eight
years old oh a guy that was 15. so when
I turned 15 I hold a guy that was 30.
so that's not good I thought that wasn't
good I was Tyrone I had the wrong room
around me it's possible people but today
I go to the Detention Center I go to
county jail and I speak the kids because
I don't want them to experience what I
experienced what what helps you stay on
track now other than you're a great wife
well let me stay on track now is the
desire to want to help people I have
that desire I have done so much wrong in
my life that I had a desire to want to
help somebody because if I had help if I
had a boss if I had someone to to to sit
me down and teach me what was wrong and
right if I had a father figure from a
personal family I went to the terms that
I took uh when my father when I was four
and five you teach me how to shoot guns
if he never taught me how to shoot guns
at young age like that quite damaged me
and every time my granddaddy come to
that one of the scales I would have
never shot him
because I would have had experience a
gun yeah but by him teaching me they had
a young age experience with guns it was
wrong yeah I was wrong
because it went DCF did it was uh
um
Hrs
give me HRS back then I'm sorry it was
it was HRS back then over child
committed a crime like that he went DCF
it was HRS they come and take you away
from your family oh is that right yeah
and then they send you away the New York
places I never been repo to offer a home
that was abusive that made me worrisome
I mean I'm not saying any of this was
really your fault you listen to your
story and you can kind of see where the
where the train went off the tracks yeah
but what what would you have done
differently if you had your life to live
all over again if I had my life to live
all over again
and I had it right
um parents did the right the right pair
of this stuff it had been way much
different a lot different you would have
picked different parents how to pick
different parents yeah I'd be the mom
that won a drug addict but a father that
wasn't a gangster but that's a cause
that life gave me and I had to have to
deal with it in the moment I got mature
to understand that it was wrong I no
longer do wrong things
there's a book that my mom was
interviewed in
and they asked her what what advice
would they give kind of like the
question I asked at the end of my videos
and she said uh pick your parents well
well that's that sound good but you had
no choice
but the moment you do I have a choice
that would have changed your thoughts
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life the
most important lesson I've learned about
life is to never take another man's life
no matter what the number or the money
was
no matter what the situation was a man
should never ever take another man's
life
because it affected me dearly today I
can't even sleep talking turns sleep
while I hear every voice my everybody
that he said I murdered and that's not
good other kids otherwise yeah because
you pick their family you take a father
away from his wife you take a father
away from his son you take a father away
from his daughter
his family
all right four five thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you Mark I
wish you the best of luck now you're out
thank you I hope you read a book or do a
movie or something like that I
appreciate it hell of a story thank you
all right